today I'm gonna talk to you about when
is the best time to start your first
business hi this is the Celia vagus your
host of value taming let me talk to you
about what is the best time to start
your first business have you ever asked
yourself that question well today I need
to share with you that the best time to
start your own business it's right away
did you know that the average greatest
entrepreneurs it started their own
business when they were just kids do you
have you ever seen kids having their own
little carwash or maybe selling some
candy a church or maybe the Boy Scouts
or the Girl Scouts knocking at your door
selling you some coupons some discount
coupons or selling you some cookies well
I have found out by doing research that
average intrapreneur that they have
succeed in their business they have
started their first business with degra
kids and I have started to thinking to
myself well I remember my first business
was actually when I was about 18 years
old and I had started a carwash
during summer my little sister and I we
started this carwash where where we'll
knock at your door and we will ask you
if we can watch your car and we will use
all your supplies but our pitch was that
we will let you say a rat of your house
you didn't need it to drive anywhere
we're gonna do it right at your garage
and we had a great success in just a
couple of weeks we had all the kids
around her block they were working for
us and they were helping us out by
knocking doors and it was a great
success that summer I'll still remember
what I bought after that summer just
because that little business now why is
it that average intrapreneur that have
become successful they started a
business when they were kids
well thinking to yourself what is
different between a kid and somebody
that's an adult wanted to start a
business when when we're a kid we really
are not even worried about rejection
we're not worried about failing so let's
talk about failing today
when you think about failing that is the
biggest fear that everybody has when
we're gonna start our business well I'm
an adult what if what if something bad
happened what if I just don't make it
why do you fight lose my investment so
let me share with you this story that I
recently read there was four monkeys and
what the scientists did was they put the
monkeys four monkeys
inside of a room and they put a big pole
inside of the room and what they did is
they put a bunch of bananas on top of a
pole and they had the first monkey that
was very hungry he started climbing and
right when he was about to grab the
first banana he got a brush of water
very very cold water on top of him so
obviously he was thrown down to the the
floor then the second monkey went ahead
and started climbing and he happened to
him the same and the same to the third
one and the same to the fourth one so
what happened after a little while is
that they stopped trying to climb that
pole what happened was that the
scientist decided to take one monkey out
and put another monkey a new monkey back
into the room so as soon as that monkey
saw the bananas
guess what he wanted to do exactly that
he wanted to climb and grab the banana
but he was starting to climb when all
the other three monkeys came around to
him and pulled him down to the floor and
he didn't understand why so he did it
again and the three monkeys came back
and put him down to the ground again and
that happened over and over again till
he stopped trying then the next thing
the scientist did was that they started
to eat one by one and replacing with you
monkeys into the room after a little
while obviously all the four new monkeys
before new monk is that word in that
room were all new monkeys but none of
them were trying to climb to get the
bananas none of them knew why we were
not supposed to get those bananas well
that's exactly
happens when we are wanting to start a
business we just don't know why we
shouldn't do it but so many people have
told us that we can get rejected that we
can fail that we that what if we don't
made it so we start measuring ourselves
by the accomplishments or by the
failures of other people my thought that
I wanted to share with you today is you
need to get up get over it and get going
you're more than likely to us into
feeling that feel into acting that's my
message for you today please make sure
that you subscribe to the link below I'm
Cecilia Vargas your host of value
teaming thank you for watching